si vous me le permettez je ne dresserai
peut-être en quelques mots des quelques
éléments de bilan sur la mise en oeuvre
de cette politique au cours des
dernières années et mettre en mettant
aussi l'accent sur les sujets qui nous
tiennent le plus à coeur qui sont les
priorités du gouvernement en ce début
d'année 2023 et bien sûr je serai à
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
interrogations sur ce sujet qui est
assez vaste et qui implique à la fois de
nombreux produits de nombreux publics
cibles mais aussi de nombreuses
préoccupations de politiques publiques
donc peut-être quelques mots de bilan
alors si j'évoque un bilan c'est parce
que nous arrivons au terme d'un exercice
de programmation gouvernementale qui
était le plan national de mobilisation
contre les addictions
2018-2022 et qui a permis déjà
d'accentuer les efforts des pouvoirs
publics dans ce domaine de la lutte
contre les conduites addictives et qui
nous a permis d'atteindre aussi un
certain nombre de résultats qui se
traduisent par des évolutions positives
d'un le nombre de consommation et que
pourra vous présenter Julien Morel
Darleux par la suite alors quels sont
les événements marquants de ces
dernières années qui se traduisent aussi
par quelques résultats en ce début 2023
c'est d'abord une meilleure information
de la population sur les risques et un
certain nombre d'usages
à ma formation sur les risques liés à la
consommation de tabac je commence par le
tabac puisque il s'agit en termes de
morbi mortalité du principal défi qui
continue à se poser à nous puisqu'il y a
encore plus de 70 000 morts par an liés
à la consommation de tabac à un nombre
considérable de pathologies liées à ce
produit donc cela reste vraiment notre
priorité principale en termes de si on
le prend sous l'angle la morbi mortalité
de comme vous le savez des une politique
désormais inscrite dans la durée a été
déployée au cours des années des
dernières années c'est incarné dans des
programmes national de lutte contre le
tabagisme de deux exercices sont déjà pu
être conduits un troisième est en cours
de préparation et pourra être annoncé
par le gouvernement au cours des
prochaines semaines et c'est traduit par
une mobilisation concomitante d'un
certain nombre de leviers leviers du
prix le paquet neutre mais aussi tout un
effort porté sur ce qu'on appelle la
dénormalisation du tabac dans notre
société donc pour faire apparaître à la
plus clairement aux yeux de la
population les risques liés à cette
substance alors peut-être pour juste
citer quelques opérations emblématiques
qui ont pu être reconduites et en
renforcée ce sont les opérations dites
moi sans tabac qui est pilotée par santé
publique France qui l'apporte un message
très clair sur
l'avantage de cesser la con de la
consommation de tabac avantage en termes
de santé avantage en termes de qualité
de vie mais aussi désormais de pouvoir
d'achat puisque c'est une préoccupation
pour bien sûr l'ensemble des citoyens
mais on sait qu'un fumeur le fume
quelqu'un qui consomme un paquet par
exemple de cigarettes par jour c'est
plus de 3000 euros dépensé pour ce
produit donc c'est aussi un gain de
pouvoir un gain de pouvoir d'achat de
pouvoir s'arrêter de fumer
autre information sur les risques qui
ont pu être conduites c'est sur l'alcool
je cite ce produit en deuxième puisque
c'est plus de 40 000 morts par an on a
là aussi beaucoup de risques non
seulement sanitaires mais aussi sociaux
associés à ce produit et j'y reviendrai
sur l'importance de l'alcool dans
l'ensemble des phénomènes de violence
dans notre pays mais ce qui a été
notamment fait au cours des dernières
années c'est le déploiement là aussi de
campagne d'information sur les risques
liés à la consommation d'alcool
notamment pour faire porter à
connaissance des Françaises qu'on
appelle les repères de consommation à
moindre risque pas plus de divers
d'alcool par semaine donc pas plus de
deux verres par jour et pas tous les
jours puisque on sait qu'on a quand même
une des risques qui sont de moins de
ampleur si on est en dessous de ses
repères or on a encore un quart de la
population française qui ces usages se
situent au-dessus de ces repères de
consommation à moins de risques tout
l'importance de les porter à la
connaissance du public donc cela aussi
sous ces traduit par des campagnes
menées sous l'égide de santé publique
France
troisième produit le cannabis donc nous
avons dans notre pays encore 900000
usagers quotidiens de cannabis donc en
termes de diffusion dans la population
là encore c'est un une préoccupation
majeure pour le gouvernement
les risques liés à l'usage de cannabis
sont de mieux en mieux documentés par la
littérature scientifique on sait en
particulier à quel point il s'agit d'une
bombe pour le cerveau des plus jeunes et
quand je dis des plus jeunes je parle
des jeunes jusqu'à 25 ans puisqu'on a un
phénomène de maturation cérébrale
jusqu'à peu près cet âge-là donc on ne
parle pas que des mineurs on parle bien
des des enfants des adolescents et des
jeunes majeurs et on sait désormais les
faits du cannabis sur ses cerveaux ça se
traduit par des troubles notamment de la
concentration de la mémoire de
l'attention avec un impact avéré sur la
réussite scolaire et l'insertion sociale
et professionnelle ultérieure donc par
exemple l'Inserm ma document a suivi des
corps de jeunes entre ceux qui avaient
eu un usage précoce et un usage régulier
sans être très intense de cannabis ceux
qui n'en n'avait pas eu et on voit un
vrai décrochage à mesurer à bac + 3
entre ces deux ces deux groupes tels que
ça a été mesuré donc sous l'égide du
service d'information et du gouvernement
de série de campagnes ont pu être
diffusées en 2021 et en 2022 donc une
campagne plus axée sur la distillation
de la population générale axée sur les
risques liés au cannabis aussi en termes
de trafic on pourra y revenir une
campagne sous l'égide de santé publique
France plus destiné aux jeunes usagers
pour là aussi les aider à la
connaissance des risques et les orientés
vers des solutions de réduction de leur
consommation voire d'arrêt et enfin une
campagne sous l'égide de la sécurité
routière pour mettre aussi l'accent sur
les risques bien sûr en termes de
conduite automobile liées aux
stupéfiants
alors au-delà des informations sur les
risques c'est bien sûr un aspect très
important mais qui ne suffit pas en
matière de prévention ce qui s'est
vraiment développé au cours des
dernières années c'est ce sont le les
programmes dit de renforcement des
compétences psychosociales alors
derrière ce terme se cache des choses à
la fois assez simples et assez difficile
à mettre en œuvre assez simple parce
qu'on parle de compétences essentielles
dans la pour la vie dans la société
c'est l'estime de soi savoir recours à
l'adulte savoir résister à la pression
des pères faire ses propres choix donc
c'est une série de compétences dont
l'enjeu de doter les enfants et
adolescents mais me voir même les
adultes on a aussi maintenant des
programmes plus à destination de des
adultes pour les aider à savoir
ne pas aborder des
comportements à risque les comportements
à risque dont les conduites addictifs
font partie donc ce sont des programmes
déployés en milieu scolaire mais pas
seulement milieu scolaire aussi dans les
autres milieux de vie de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent d'abord de façon un peu
expérimentale vous aussi évaluer
l'efficacité de ces programmes et
désormais on arrive à un déploiement un
peu plus avancé je n'ose pas parler de
généralisation parce qu'on en est pas
encore là mais désormais dans chaque
région de françaises généralement dans
le cadre de partenariat entre le
rectorat et l'Agence régionale de santé
on a des établissements scolaires qui
bénéficient de ce de ces programmes de
renforcement des compétences
psychosociales alors ils sont souvent
déployés avec l'aide de d'acteurs du
monde de la santé et de la prévention
dont notamment fédération addiction qui
a été beaucoup à la manœuvre sur le
programme dans les collèges Guillaume
pluggde et qui mais l'enjeu désormais
est de bien sûr l'intégrer dans les
pratiques éducatives ordinaires et donc
de toucher aussi la formation initiale
et contenu des enseignants et au-delà
des enseignants de la communauté
éducative plus généralement pour que
cela puisse infuser largement les
pratiques éducatives et pédagogiques du
de l'éducation nationale je parlais
d'autres milieux de vie de l'enfant et
de l'adoles peut-être juste pour
mentionner que l'enseignement agricole
est aussi très actif sur ces sujets et à
de nombreux programmes de renforcement
des compétences psychosociales dans son
enfin dans ces établissements on a aussi
construit des choses dans des
établissements tels que lipides pour les
jeunes décrocheurs qui reprennent une
formation
et on tente aussi de déployer ce type
d'approche dans tous les établissements
et services qui accueillent des jeunes
relevant de la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse ou de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance donc on n'est pas au bout de
ce chemin mais il est vraiment labouré
par l'ensemble des acteurs et ça s'est
traduit par une instruction
interministérielle adoptée en août 2022
notamment
toujours dans cette effort porté aux
plus jeunes on vous bénéfice des plus
jeunes peut-être mentionné la
constitution de ce qu'on appelle les
environnements protecteurs certes il
s'agit de doter chacun de des
informations sur les risques de la
liberté de choisir mais aussi de
constituer un environnement qui soit
protecteur pour lui et bien sûr en
priorité les enfants et adolescents qui
sont parmi les publics les plus
vulnérables quand on parle de conduite
addictives alors quelles sont ces
ingrédients d'environnement protecteurs
c'est d'abord le respect de ce qu'on
appelle volontiers les interdits
protecteurs alors le premier d'entre eux
c'est l'interdiction de vente d'alcool
de tabac de jeux d'argent et de hasard
désormais de protoxyde d'azote au moins
de 18 ans c'est une interdiction qui
accorde largement pas respectée en
France les chiffres quand on fait des
enquêtes clients mystères sont assez
dramatiques puisqu'on a plus de 9
enfants sur 10 qui disent n'avoir aucun
une difficulté à s'approvisionner auprès
des débutants de boissons de tabac de
jeux d'argent et de hasard
on a plus de plus de 10% des buralistes
qui vendent sans sourciller à des
enfants de 12 ans dans les enquêtes
clients mystères alors que normalement
l'exigence une pièce d'identité est
inscrite dans la loi on a encore trop
peu de contrôle trop peu de sanctions et
notamment des sanctions aussi qui
seraient connues et qui pour avoir un
effet dissuasif donc c'est un effort
continu là encore on a fait beaucoup de
choses en matière de formation de
débutant de campagne de sensibilisation
en s'appuyant aussi les têtes de pont
que sont par exemple l'humili la
Fédération du commerce et la
distribution la Confédération des
buralistes etc mais on sent on voit
malheureusement que ces opérations ne
suffisent pas elles seules et ce qu'il
faut désormais c'est aussi mobiliser les
forces de sécurité intérieure polices
gendarmerie pour mener des contrôles les
polices municipales sur le tabac et jeux
d'argent et de hasard puisqu'ils ont ils
sont fiabilité à le faire en la matière
la justice pour qu'elle puisse prononcer
des sanctions et les faire connaître
donc c'est vraiment un sujet auquel on
tient beaucoup parce qu'on a des preuves
scient selon laquelle réduire
l'accessibilité des produits pour les
mineurs c'est efficace en matière de de
réduction des consommations il peut
toujours y avoir des phénomènes de
contournement envoyer un ami prendre les
produits mis à disposition par les
parents mais malgré tout tant que cette
interdit n'est pas respecté on a un
angle mort dans notre politique publique
autre interdit auquel on tient beaucoup
c'est aussi faire respecter toutes les
règles relatives à la publicité la
publicité si elle est déployée
massivement c'est parce qu'elle a un
impact sur les consommations c'est une
incitation à consommer dont sont
victimes en particulier les plus jeunes
on a des un corpus législatif qui existe
qui est certes ça peut perfectible mais
qui a quand même le mérite d'exister que
je pense notamment à l'alcool je pense
aussi aux jeux d'argent et de hasard on
a de une nouvelle règle réglementation
qui est toute récente de 2020 l'enjeu
c'est de faire respecter cette
réglementation et de réduire un peu le
matraquage promotionnel dans son victime
les enfants adolescents mais aussi
jeunes adultes
et on voit bien à quel point c'est ces
stratégies cibles c'est plus jeune pour
recruter là de nouveaux consommateurs
l'environnement protecteur c'est aussi
la sensibilisation des adultes de tous
les adultes qui entourent les enfants
alors les parents en premier lieu d'où
si l'importance de l'information sur les
risques il faut que les parents sachent
par exemple ce les risques liés à la
consommation de cannabis il est leurs
adolescents le font mais aussi parce
qu'ils ont un rôle
primordial à jouer on a encore en France
une initiation qui se fait à certains
produits trop souvent en famille et là
il y a deux produits un peu phares
malheureusement la matière c'est
l'alcool premièrement on a encore 44%
des enfants de 6e qui ont déjà goûté de
l'alcool en sixième c'est pas avec les
copains c'est dans le cercle familial
donc ce sont généralement à l'occasion
de faire de famille parfois sous le
couvert d'éducation goût mais on a
encore des pratiques familiales qui qui
conduisent à une initiation beaucoup
trop précoce en matière d'alcool et on
se situe de très loin par rapport à tous
les autres pays européens en la matière
autre produit ce sont les jeux d'argent
et de hasard là aussi sans penser à mal
souvent initiation se fait des mineurs
se fait en compagnie des parents on va
acheter un jeu de grattage dans un point
de vente Française des jeux on fait des
paris sportifs ensemble en ligne devant
le match du jour mais là encore on sait
que ces initiations trop précoces ont
des impacts ensuite sur les conduites
addictives des jeunes devenus adultes
donc là encore des messages importants à
faire passer sur le rôle de chacun et
sur la nécessaire mobilisation des
adultes on rêve qu'un jour dans la queue
dans un buraliste les adultes ces meufs
lorsque le buraliste vend un paquet de
tabac un mineur et puisque cette
tolérance sociale à la vente aux mineurs
elle aussi baisse
l'environnement protecteur ça vaut pour
les enfants adolescents ça vaut aussi
dans d'autres milieux de vie et donc ce
sont aussi des des orientations que nous
avons adoptées que nous souhaitons
renforcer au cours des prochaines années
je pense par exemple au milieu
professionnel on sait que on a longtemps
un peu pensé que il y avait une
séparation entre les
usages de substances psychoactives en
milieu privé les usages en milieu
professionnel en fait non c'est deux
usages
sont liés bien sûr et on sait que à la
fois les ce que ça emporte pour les
entreprises d'avoir des des salariés qui
ont des conduites addictives il y a un
vrai aussi enjeu économique de bien-être
des salariés mais on sait aussi que le
milieu professionnel lui-même a une un
rôle à jouer c'est à dire qu'on a des
milieux de vie qui en milieu
professionnel qui sont plus ou moins
protecteurs alors ça paraît un peu
théorique mais en fait je vais prendre
quelques exemples très pratiques tout ce
qui est habitude en milieu professionnel
de faire des peaux alcoolisées
que ce soit des afterwork des pots de
départ des pots pour fêter tel ou tel
succès on sait que cela pouvait aussi
être autant d'incitation à consommer
donc le message est un de faire
respecter là aussi la loi puisque la loi
limite le type d'alcool qui peut être
opposé mais aussi de d'inciter à
proposer aussi des boissons non
alcoolisées vraiment laisser le choix
aussi aux personnes de ne pas consommer
d'alcool alors je parle d'alcool mais on
a aussi d'autres milieux professionnels
soumis par exemple à de fortes exigences
de performance et on sait maintenant que
la cocaïne notamment c'est un produit
que je n'ai pas encore évoqué mais se
diffuse en France
l'offre de cocaïne est très abondante
d'où une forte mobilisation des services
de l'ordre on pourra en reparler mais on
a aussi des usages qui sont en
augmentation alors ils sont encore sans
commune mesure avec ceux du cannabis si
on reste dans le domaine des stupé enfin
des drogues illicites mais l'usage
augmente ça nous préoccupe énormément et
on dépasse désormais les milieux un peu
classiques
traditionnels auxquels on pense on
pensait au trader les milieux de la pub
enfin c'est des images un peu
caricaturales mais on est désormais
confronté notamment dans certains
milieux professionnels à des usages
croissants de cocaïne
alors quelques exemples juste mais c'est
pas du tout exclusif et c'est
certainement pas pour les stigmatiser on
sait que dans le milieu de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie on a ce
type d'usage qui se développe avec des
incitations aussi à la consommation pour
les plus jeunes salariés de ce secteur
je pense aussi à des milieux comme les
marins-pêcheurs les métiers souvent très
durs le DTP ou la cocaïne est prise
aussi pour ses effets
perçus comme aidant à la performance
donc voilà on se cite rapidement ce
milieu professionnel un dernier milieu
de vie et j'en finirai là ce panorama
sur les milieux de vie c'est celui des
milieux de vie étudiants ou uniforme
aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire donc nous avons lancé une démarche
avec le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur pour inciter les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur université grandes écoles à là
aussi être conscient
de la manière dont se l'environnement
dans lequel évolue les étudiants et plus
ou moins incitatif ou protecteur
vis-à-vis des conduites addictives alors
quand on parle d'étudiants on pense
souvent juste au milieu festif il est
certes important donc tout ce qui est
prévention et réduitrices en milieu
festifs cela reste une partie importante
de notre politique publique mais au-delà
du de la vie festive il y a aussi tout
ce qui se passe sur les campus dans les
dans les logements étudiants dans la vie
associative les clubs sportifs les clubs
de loisirs les associations multiples
qui existent sur un campus où là encore
on il est important que les adultes
enfin les adultes ils sont tous adultes
à sages là mais en tout cas les
encadrants et un discours public et un
discours clair vis-à-vis des étudiants
qu'il n'y ait pas d'incitation à
consommer et au contraire qu'il y ait
des facteurs protecteurs pour ces jeunes
adultes dont nous avons vu tout à
l'heure la vulnérabilité donc ça peut
passer par des espaces sans tabac on a
des universités qui déploient désormais
ce genre d'approche un discours clair
sur l'alcool aussi je pense que tant que
les directs dirigeants des des
universités des grandes écoles ne
mettent pas de fin à cette idée selon
lequel les consommations massives
d'alcool ça fait partie d'un rites
initiatique d'un passage obligé il faut
que jeunesse se fasse donc on aura ce
genre de discours porté par les
encadrants dans les universités on aura
du mal à progresser et
ça passe aussi par une sensibilisation
des salariés de tous ces établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs pour que eux
aussi puissent profiter d'un
environnement plus protecteur
je peut-être juste deux trois mentions
pour finir et ensuite je répondrai bien
sûr à pendant la suite de la discussion
à vos interrogations peut-être pour
mentionner l'importance aussi de la
réduction des risques qui est donc une
approche qui permet de pour ceux qui
consomment des produits à quel qu'il
soit alcool drogues illicit de réduire
les risques associés à ces consommations
donc on a là aussi une politique qui
s'est poursuivie au cours des dernières
années qui a cherché à amplifier ces
démarches depuis la loi de 2016 la
réduction des risques est clairement
inscrit dans la loi avec tout ce que
cela implique en termes de
reconnaissance de la légitimité de cette
politique de protection des intervenants
de matière de réduction des risques en
développement de nouveaux outils alors
il y a un exemple qui est souvent
emblématique dans le débat public mais
qui ne résume pas à lui seul et
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus l'approche
réduction des risques c'est ce qu'on
appelait les salles de consommation à
moins de risques désormais halte soins
addiction
au cours des dernières années donc on a
pu conduire ces deux expérimentations à
Paris à Strasbourg sur tous les évalués
avec un programme ambition des marchands
d'évaluation qui a mis en évidence
l'efficacité de ce type de dispositif et
comme vous le savez bien nous sommes
désormais confrontés au défi de
stabilisation de du dispositifs
notamment à Paris mais aussi d'ouverture
éventuellement de nouvelles elles se
sont addictions sur les territoires ou
ses ouvertures sont justifiées lorsqu'il
y a des scènes ouvertes de consommation
lorsqu'il y a aussi une alliance des
acteurs locaux pour porter ce type de
dispositif mais c'est un dispositif dans
une palette d'outils donc la réduction
des risques ce n'est pas que ça c'est
aussi des démarches qui se construisent
dans beaucoup de dispositifs je pense
notamment à tout ce qui est centre
d'hébergement par exemple tous les
établissements et services de du secteur
de l'accueil hébergement insertion là
aussi c'est important de savoir comment
accompagner les
usagers de substances psychoactives pour
réduire les risques c'est aussi la
réduction des risques en milieu
là encore quand on a des grands
événements festifs il faut savoir
intervenir pour réduire les risques
associés
pardon j'avais un dernier point que je
voulais évoquer oui alors bien sûr c'est
la lutte contre les trafics mais qui
s'est renforcé depuis 2019 avec un
premier plan national de lutte contre
les trafics et un renouvellement un
approfondissement de cet exercice qui
est prévu pour 2023 donc là aussi c'est
une mobilisation très massive des forces
de sécurité intérieure police
gendarmerie les douanes aussi qui sont
très impliqués dans cette politique
toute la chaîne pénale pour avoir une
action déterminée à la fois sur la
criminalité organisée les grosses têtes
de pont en matière de trafic mais aussi
le trafic du quotidien parce que cette
sécurité au quotidien c'est une
préoccupation aussi première du
gouvernement qui se traduit notamment
par toutes ces efforts portés sur le
démantèlement des points de Deal et
dernière chose mais qui n'est pas la
moindre moins importante c'est le
renforcement des dynamiques
territoriales en matière lutte contre
les addictions il y a eu beaucoup
d'évolution au cours des dernières
années et notre ambition c'est de les
renforcer
alors premièrement au niveau des acteurs
de l'État au niveau local je pense aux
préfectures qui sont nos relais de la
Milka au niveau local qui ont écrit des
feuilles de route régionale en 2019
alors certes c'était un premier exercice
très perfectible mais il a traduit la
mobilisation interministérielle des
acteurs au niveau des régions et d'un
département
ce sont aussi les agences régionales de
santé qui se sont vu dotées de moyens
significativement plus élevés au cours
des dernières années grâce au Front
national de lutte contre les addictions
donc les agences régionales de santé ont
des crédits ont des politiques désormais
stabilisées au niveau régional pour
mener des actions ambitieuses en matière
de prévention et d'accompagnement et de
réduction des risques dans le domaine de
la lutte contre les conduites addictives
et c'est enfin le se sont enfin les
collectivités locales qui sont qui ont
vraiment contribué de plus en plus à
cette politique vous le savez peut-être
la 1000 décale lance depuis 2018 les
appels à projets des nationaux à
destination des communes et
intercommunalités on a un succès grand
avec ses appels à projets et nous en
réjouissons vraiment on a désormais à
chaque appel à projet plus d'une
centaine de candidatures de dossiers
déposés ce qui nous a permis de conclure
au cours des dernières années 50 une
cinquantaine de partenariats avec des
communes et intercommunalités de toutes
tailles sur l'ensemble du territoire en
métropole ou en outre-mer avec des
projets assez divers parce que ce qui
nous semblait essentiel c'est de
respecter l'orientation politique donnée
par l'élu le maire ces adjoints certains
privilégie une approche autour de
l'accompagnement de famille la
prévention telle plus jeune âge d'autres
souhaitent mettre l'accent aussi sur
l'application de la loi qui reste un
sujet très important comme je le disais
tout à l'heure sur sur aussi la
responsabilisation des débutants par
exemple donc on a des projets
avec des intonations toutes les nuances
mais tous sont le mérite d'être portés
par les lieux locales d'être de
mobiliser l'ensemble des services de la
commune puisque il ne s'est pas
seulement un sujet sanitaire comme vous
le savez c'est un sujet qui beaucoup
plus largement les services communaux on
a aussi des projets qui se déroulent à
destination des agences des communes
parce que comme je le disais ça à cause
un sujet qui concerne aussi le maire en
tant qu'employeur et qui nous permette
vraiment d'avoir des dynamiques
territoriales très intéressantes et que
nous souhaitons approfondir au cours des
prochaines années je vais m'arrêter là
je vais sans doute été un peu long mais
c'était pour un panorama un peu global
et surtout je reste monsieur à
disposition pour vos questions et je
n'ai pas parlé de chiffres en termes de
pratique et de consommation puisque je
crois que c'est en cycle de l'eau très
bien donc je laisse la parole à Monsieur
Julien Morel
oui merci Madame la présente bonjour
mesdames et messieurs je vous remercie
de cette audition
je relance le diaporama voilà donc merci
de nous accueillir aujourd'hui on était
dans la même configuration au Disney par
votre commission il y a un peu plus d'un
an à l'issue de la crise sanitaire et
donc je ne vais pas revenir sur
l'ensemble des données produites par
l'Observatoire français des drogues et
des tendances addictives en particulier
parce que nous veillons à accusé ces
données à les rendre disponibles le plus
régulièrement possible et donc on a
réédité donc cette brochure drogue et
addiction chiffre clé au printemps 2022
et normalement c'est le poste fait bien
son travail vous avez dû le recevoir vos
collaborateurs ont dû le recevoir durant
l'été donc voilà c'est pour nous c'était
un élément important de vous transmettre
ces données qui sont actualisées sur
lesquels on pourra revenir de manière
plus générale je voulais vous présenter
aujourd'hui les derniers chiffres
d'évolution des consommations en
population adulte pour le cannabis et
pour l'ensemble des drogues illicités
des pour les adolescents à 17 ans alors
une partie de ces données ont été
publiées au mois de décembre avec
l'Agence de santé publique santé
publique France dans le cadre des
publications des résultats du Baromètre
santé 2021 pour le pour le cannabis dans
notre vue tendance et une autre partie
que je vais vous présenter de manière
synthétique va être publiée au mois de
mars puisqu'on a pu réaliser j'y
reviendrai avec le soutien du ministère
des armées l'enquête escapade auprès de
23000 jeunes donc il dit une enquête au
monde la journée d'appel à la défense
23000 jeunes de 17 ans qui a été réalisé
donc en mars 2022 et
nos équipes sont aménagé leurs efforts
pour pouvoir présenter des résultats
moins d'un an après après la réalisation
de cette enquête parce que c'est la
première enquête de cette ampleur en
population adolescente après la crise
sanitaire il me semblait important avec
les chiffres d'aventure 2017 de
[Musique]
pourcentage directement
donc voilà donc ça c'est un point
important donc on a profité de ce
changement de ce changement de
périmètre d'action pour aussi faire
évoluer cette occasion à nos
localisation de nos 25 ans d'activités
faire évoluer notre logo et surtout
notre nom et donc nous appelons toujours
FDT en abréviation mais c'est
l'observateur français des drogues des
tendances addictives afin de couvrir
l'ensemble du champ le terme tendance
est important pour nous en tant
qu'observatoire puisque ce qui fait
aussi la force de notre dispositif c'est
d'être régulièrement répété et de
pouvoir mesurer dans le temps les
évolutions comme je vais vous le montrer
alors juste un point de rappel mais
maintenant je pense que chacun d'entre
vous maîtrise ses données mais on va
plus parler effectivement
d'expérimentation c'est dire le fait
d'avoir
une pratique comme le gingembre une fois
dans la vie ou avoir consommé un produit
une fois dans sa vie en tant
qu'expérimentation et on est
expérimentateur toute sa vie ça permet
de savoir finalement comment un produit
une pratique est diffusé dans notre pays
mais ce qui va nous intéresser est-ce
que je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui
c'est d'abord effectivement ce qu'on
appelle les usages dans l'année les oges
actuelles c'est-à-dire les personnes qui
ont eu cette pratique ou ce comportement
ou cette consommation dans l'année qui
qui s'est écoulé qui est avant avant
l'enquête et plus spécifiquement donc on
ressait à la focale sur l'usage récent
c'est-à-dire l'usage dans le mois et
après l'usage régulier c'est quand il y
a 10 fois cet usage dans le mois voilà
je voulais juste rappeler ces éléments
avant de vous montrer quelques pour
donner quelques données alors sur
l'évolution donc des des usages de
cannabis en population adulte en France
on a donc c'est une publication qu'on a
fait accentuer publique France donc en
décembre 2022 donc c'est le résultat du
barreau de santé 2021 qui a permis
d'interroger près de 23000 personnes
d'adultes donc de 18 à 64 ans pour les
usagers de drogue et visite ce que l'on
note dans cette évolution c'est que
alors on n'a pas avoir mis la cour parce
qu'elle continue à progresser la courbe
de l'expérimentation puisque comme je le
disais on est expérimentateur toute sa
vie donc on a une génération
vieillissante de
d'explorateurs de cannabis on est
aujourd'hui un peu moins de la moitié
des 18 64 ans qui ont déjà expérimenté
le cannabis donc c'est c'est une légère
hausse par rapport à 2017
l'analyse précédente qui avait été faite
avec l'incendie dans lequel illicite
mais par contre et je pense c'est un des
éléments importants que l'on voit donc
sur les trois dernières les trois
derniers points de la courbe comme vous
le voyez on a donc 2017 qui est notre
année de référence avant la crise
sanitaire et avec son public France il y
a eu deux mesures en 2020 donc pendant
la crise sanitaire et en 2021 des usages
de cannabis donc on voit en fait non on
a souhaité dans ce numéro de tendance
faire une comparaison
2017-2021 c'est à dire sur sur 5 années
et on voit que l'usage dans l'année est
resté stable aux alentours de d'un peu
plus de 10 % d'ici 8% des des adultes
qui ont consommé du cannabis dans
l'année mais par contre les usages au
cours du moins et les yeux réguliers
c'est-à-dire des fois par mois sont en
baisse l'usage quotidien et lui aussi en
baisse chez les adultes donc on a un
élève deux éléments marquants c'est
qu'on a toujours une prédominance
masculine dans les usages ça c'est c'est
un invariant et le deuxièmement le
deuxième point et ça je pense c'est un
élément important qu'on a qu'on a
souligné dans le dans le tendance c'est
qu'on a en fait un vieillissement des
usagers
pour avoir un un exemple par classe
d'âge c'est la première fois que j'ai 18
24 ans
le nombre d'expérimentateurs et est en
baisse par rapport donc aux années
précédentes et donc en fait on a une
évolution
qui est qui est finalement qui va se
traduire on va le voir après sur les
enquêtes qu'on a fait en population de
l'essence c'est-à-dire que finalement le
c'est consommation de cannabis dans
notre pays sont partis plus parlé 25 45
ans que de leçons parler
18-24 ans aujourd'hui avec en
particulier je me permets de souligner
ce point puisque c'est un élément qui
est
qui est marquant même si les chiffres
sont sont assez faibles mais on a une
augmentation des usages c'est donc des
usages dans l'année chez les 59 55 64
ans donc voilà ça reste extrêmement
minime mais c'est des évolutions on voit
donc cette notion de vieillissement des
usages qui ce qui se traduit de manière
continue c'est un mouvement de de qui ce
qui se traduit de plusieurs années alors
deuxième élément qui que vous
retrouverez dans ce numéro et qui je
pense intéressera directement votre
commission c'est on a pu publier
donc une évolution donc des des usages
par région territoriale la taille de
l'échantillon du baron de santé permet
ses évolutions un élément extrêmement
important dans les discussions qu'on a
pu avoir santé publique France et qui
était attendu je pense pas pas par vous
et pas les membres du gif c'est on a pu
publier aussi ces données
en même temps pour les territoires
ultramarins enfin donc les la Guadeloupe
la Guyane de Martinique et la Réunion
qui ont suffisamment de de
d'habitants pour pouvoir réaliser cette
enquête en population générale dans le
dans le même temps et donc c'est assez
intéressant parce que on a une carte de
France qui est assez hétérogène on n'a
pas reproduit sous format de carte
aujourd'hui mais on le fera
prochainement on a des des fiches
territoriales je vois que ça génère un
certain nombre de commentaires mais on
pourra y revenir tout à l'heure
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y a très
contrasté donc sur le sur le territoire
national c'est assez hétérogène dans
l'Hexagone il y a néanmoins contraste
Nord-Sud avec trois régions qui se
distinguent sur des usages qui sont plus
importants qui sont la nouvelle
Aquitaine l'Occitanie et la provenance
al Côte d'Azur donc c'est c'est un
élément qui qui est à noter l'autre
élément qui est à noter donc c'est les
données qui apparaissent en rouge
lorsqu'il y a une des
usages qui sont plus importants avec la
moyenne nationale
l'autre élément important à retenir en
la matière c'est que les finalement les
les la diffusion l'exploitation du
cannabis dans les territoires
ultramarins et moins importante la
première colonne qu'elle est conne de
l'expérimentation est en bleu pour ces
pour ces quatre territoires mais on a
par contre dans les usages de l'année
finalement des niveaux d'usage qui sont
pas significativement différents de ceux
de la de la du territoire hexagonal et
donc on a finalement un produit qui est
moins diffusé mais qui reste consommé
par donc une frange de la population de
manière similaire à ce que l'on a sur le
territoire hexagonal voilà les premiers
éléments on pourra y revenir bien
évidemment tout à l'heure et donc je
vous présente quelques éléments donc sur
l'enquête sur la santé des consommations
lors de la Journée d'appel à la défense
est-ce qu'il y a pas donc qui
aujourd'hui corrige d'ailleurs la
journée défense citoyenneté donc c'est
un partenariat qu'on a depuis 20 ans
maintenant un peu plus de 20 ans avec le
ministère des armées la direction du
service national et la jeunesse qui nous
permet d'interroger
donc ça a été mis en oeuvre au moment de
la création de l'OFDT avec le soutien de
la mine décale à l'époque enfin la milte
à l'époque qui permet d'interroger toute
une classe d'âge donc de manière
régulière et donc c'était le 10ème
exercice depuis 2000 le premier exercice
depuis 2017 comme je l'évoquais donc ça
permet une enquête qui reprend tactile
dès qu'on consommation chez jeunes
Français à 17 ans cette enquête elle a
un questionnaire qui est stabilisé dans
le temps et qui permet d'interroger à la
fois les questions des usages de
produits comme j'ai évoqué mais
également les depuis 2011 on a des
questions sur les jeux d'argent et de
hasard et c'est un élément sur lequel je
voudrais insister aujourd'hui on a aussi
un mode de tout un module de question
sur la santé physique et mentale des
jeunes et je pense que c'est un des
points que que l'on va voir ensemble
alors l'enquête a eu lieu en mars 2022
sur une semaine la mission des armées a
fait tous ses efforts pour nous
permettre de convoquer près de 25000
jeunes sur une semaine sur le territoire
hexagonal on va réaliser dans les
territoires ultramarins cette enquête
puisque jusqu'à lors on irait réaliser
en même temps sur en dans l'Hexagone et
sur les territoires compte tenu des
délais de
convocation sur une semaine on ne
pouvait pas le réaliser dans les
outre-mer l'année dernière donc on va le
faire cette année avec la direction du
service national et de la jeunesse donc
on aura un petit décalage sur les
données mais on pourra continuer à avoir
cette enquête sur l'ensemble du
territoire national en tout on a 22430
de 17 ans qui ont répondu à cette
à cette enquête avec le département et
le sextant signé je le dis c'est
important pour les analystères que l'on
fera ensuite et je le disais en
introduction c'est la première enquête
de cette ampleur que l'on a réalisé
auprès de la population adolescente
alors quelques données générales sur ces
premiers résultats que l'on est toujours
en cours de de finalisation et avant de
les valoriser au mois de au mois de mars
la première donnée importante et je
reviendrai de manière plus détaillée
juste après c'est la baisse très forte
du tabagisme je vous avais présenté en
2021 les les résultats de l'enquête en
classe en troisième qui montrait une
très forte baisse déjà de chez de 3e de
ces
consommations de tabac
cette baisse s'accentue donc on perd
quasiment 10 points de pourcentage entre
2017 et 2022 puisqu'on est aujourd'hui à
15,6% des jeunes de distance se
déclarant fumeur quotidien ils étaient
donc 25% il y a il y a 5 ans
par contre et c'est un élément sur
lequel on va continuer à travailler avec
tout un module sur le sujet c'est sur la
question de l'usage de la e-cigarette
puisque là on a un quasi par contre
doublement des usages au cours du mois
un des points de vigilance concernant la
cigarettes c'est c'est en fait lorsqu'on
interroge les jeunes ils ont parfois du
mal à dire ce qu'il y a comme E-liquide
dans le récit arrête ce qui peut
d'ailleurs générer on l'avait vu ces
dernières années aussi des des
incidences sanitaires lorsqu'il y avait
des liquides avec des nouveaux produits
de synthèse qui circulaient en milieu
scolaire
donc pour être très clair l'ensemble des
usages déclarés est en baisse sur que ce
soit sur les produits licite et
illicites sur l'alcool donc j'ai pris
j'ai pris juste ces données sur l'usage
récent c'est à dire l'usage dans le mois
donc on a aussi une baisse quasiment de
8 points des usages sur le cannabis
l'usage régulier c'est dire 10 fois par
mois on a une baisse quasiment par deux
on a posé pour la première fois une
question sur l'usage du CBD qui a fait
l'objet de nombreux débats et qui montre
qu'on a par contre un niveau de
diffusion qui est important à 14%
qui est donc l'usage au cours du mois et
sur les autres produits illicites on a
une baisse et le donc on passe de 6,8 à
3,9%
donc ça c'est un premier point juste un
petit focus en la matière sur le tabac
puisque c'est quand même le résultat le
plus marquant on a depuis qu'on a mis en
place l'enquête une baisse de 25 points
des usages de tabac quotidiens
depuis 2000 donc on était à 41 % en 2001
on est à 16 % aujourd'hui 9 fois moins
donc je disais tout à l'heure entre 2016
et 2022 et l'exploitation du tabac dans
la ville donc l'expérimentation du tabac
finalement est aussi en baisse un
quasiment 30 points en entre 2000 et
2022 donc c'est très clairement un effet
génération qui est qui fait suite à un
certain nombre d'interdiction qu'on peut
être mis en oeuvre c'est depuis le
milieu des années 2000 sur
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics le paquet neutre c'est tous ces
éléments en fait jouent sur
l'accessibilité à un produit et je
permet de rebondir sur ce qu'ils
observer cette voyance sur finalement
ces interdits protecteurs on a là
effectivement un effet marquant
il y a néanmoins un bémol dans à tous
ces chiffres et je pense que c'est un
élément de réflexion sur lequel nous
avons travaillé dans l'analyse de ces
résultats et pour une fois dans le dans
le numéro de tendance que nous
publierons au mois de mars on aura un
faut que je plus important que les
années précédentes sur le sujet c'est
sur la dégradation de tous les
indicateurs de santé donc je disais
depuis la même manière qu'on pose les
mêmes questions sur les usages on a un
module sur le sur les
à la fois la santé physique et la santé
psychique des adolescents avec des
questions qui sont standardisées qui
sont posées dans dans des questions dans
des question des enquêteurs en
population générale
si la consommation de médicaments et
globalement comparable à celle de 2017
on a des jeunes qui
perçoivent leur santé comme étant
mauvaises donc une augmentation de d'un
peu plus près de points on va dire ils
sont en leur demande leur taille et leur
foi donc ça nous permet de mesurer
l'IMC donc c'est quand même de voir
qu'on a en fait une augmentation du
surpoid de l'obésité avec un marqueur
plus important sur le sur l'obésité donc
on passe effectivement là aussi un peu
plus de points et demi en 5 ans on a un
centre de questions qui permet de
mesurer donc les la question des
du risque de dépression légère au sévère
et là aussi on a une hausse de 10 points
des indicateurs qui nous sont transmis
par les jeunes interrogés et enfin on a
une forte hausse des pensées suicidaires
mais aussi des tentatives de suicide
déclarées voilà c'est des questions qui
sont qui marquent de manière importante
donc une dégradation des indicateurs de
santé depuis 5 ans une évolution qui est
l'inverse à la à celle de la des usages
donc à la différence
des adultes qui qui ont pu déjà
expérimenter un produit ces jeunes n'ont
pas n'ont pas eu de sans doute de
d'opportunités pendant la crise
sanitaire en particulier pendant les
périodes de confinement de accéder à
d'autres modes de sociabilité qui aurait
pu peut-être découvrir des produits mais
aussi avoir des activités qui sont qui
leur permettrait de lutter contre ces
risques de dépression légère au sévère
ces pensées suicidaires et cette
perception globale d'une santé mauvaise
donc il y a je le pense et c'est enfin
nous le pensons c'est un élément de
vigilance de et d'attention mais je
pense que Jean-Michel de Lille rebondira
sur ce point et c'est un point également
souligné par les citoyens c'est un point
de vigilance à avoir pour pour nos
jeunes et donc dernier point donc voilà
nous allons publier donc début mars ces
résultats nous avons un focus spécifique
sur les jeux d'argent et de hasard
publié au printemps au plus tard réalité
2023 ainsi que des analyses régionales
voilà et puis donc les deux autres
publications qui sont déjà qui sont déjà
en ligne sont sur cette diapositive je
vous remercie pour votre attention merci
Docteur de Lille compléter et ensuite on
passera aux questions nous avons
beaucoup de questions
merci madame la Présidente pour votre
invitation mesdames messieurs je vous
remercie également parce qu'en
introduction vous avez évoqué la crise
qui heurte actuellement tout le système
de santé particulièrement le système de
santé mentale alors j'y suis sensible en
tant que psychiatre je suis encore plus
sensible en tant que psychiatre exerçant
dans le secteur médico-social puisque la
crise également massive y compris sous
forme de crise des ressources humaines
or néanmoins pour compléter la ce qui
vient d'être dit par nos amis aussi bien
en termes de cadrage gouvernemental
avait le plan national qu'avec
l'évolution des des données auxquelles
je souscris tout à fait de qui viennent
vous êtes présenté par l'omdt quels sont
en quelques mots les adaptations en
cours de notre secteur dans le domaine
aussi bien de la prévention des soins
que la réduction des risques en notre
secteur je suis président de la
Fédération addiction qui regroupe
environ 80% des des établissements au
niveau national donc des dès que ça pas
les centres de soins les Carus les
centres de réduction des risques sachant
que
les équipes sont des équipes
pluridisciplinaires donc ils proposent
une prise en charge globale en matière
de de prévention tout d'abord je crois
que la clé c'est ce qui vient d'être dit
actuellement et que vous aviez évoqué en
introduction c'est à dire que dans
peut-être en partie suite à la crise
sanitaire et à l'isolement des jeunes on
a on assiste à une dégradation
extrêmement sensible de la qualité de
vie et également des indicateurs de
santé mentale comme ça vient d'être
évoqué chez les chez les adolescents ça
c'est un problème en soi évidemment on
parlait des conduits suicidaires c'est
un problème aussi parce que c'est
évidemment un facteur de vulnérabilité
par rapport à une entrée dans des
consommations éventuellement ensuite
dans une transition pour des conduites
addictives donc c'est un point à
surveiller de très très près qui nous
incite non seulement à continuer à
promouvoir évidemment les actions de
soutien aux compétences psychosociales
car rappelait tout à l'heure Valérie
saint-oyan mais aussi à développer tous
les programmes liés au consultation
jeune consommateurs j'avais évoqué lors
de la réunion de décembre à l'Assemblée
nationale qui était co-animé d'ailleurs
par le sénateur yakovelli en présence du
ministre l'importance de ces structures
de terrain qui sont répartis sur tous
les territoires qui peuvent permettre de
recevoir des jeunes qui sont en
difficulté mais des jeunes n'ont de
sécurité au plan psychologiques au plan
social au plan familial ou le point
d'appel est peut-être une prise de
substance ou un abus un abus d'écran
mais où il importe évidemment d'essayer
de faire un bilan général de cette de
cette situation pour pour bien avancer
en termes de de prise en charge il faut
que nous adaptions à l'évolution des
pratiques et des consommations alors il
y a des données on le dit pas assez
peut-être parce que les
pouvoirs publics sont responsables grâce
aux plans qui se sont succédés notamment
par rapport au tabac par rapport à
l'alcool les professionnels ont dû jouer
un rôle également mais l'ensemble de la
population je crois qu'il y a une prise
de conscience et on assiste à vraiment
un effondrement des niveaux de
consommation d'alcool par rapport aux
années 60 dans notre pays avec une
mutation complète des modes consommation
avec une réduction des consommations
quotidiennes qui étaient celles de ma
génération des consommations de vins de
20 à table etc et une évolution vers
d'autres modes de pratique qui pose
d'autres problèmes le tabac ça a été
évoqué aussi ça a se réduit ça continue
à se réduire un ralentissement
actuellement mais la tendance positive
se poursuit chez les jeunes alors en
quoi ça nous concerne c'est parce que
moins il y aura de personnes en masse
dépendantes de ces produits là alcool et
tabac plus les situations les plus
difficiles les plus résistantes ceux qui
vont rester accrochés seront des
personnes qui présenteront des
comorbidités et des vulnérabilités
psychologiques et sociales c'est sûr
c'est déjà évident par rapport au tabac
où il y a un gradient social majeur
c'est un facteur majeur d'inégalité
sociale c'est vrai aussi pour l'alcool
ça commence à l'être pour le cannabis
très très nettement et là on voit bien
que pour prendre en charge ces personnes
là il faut prendre en charge aussi ces
vulnérabilités de l'intérêt des équipes
pluridisciplinaires et donc des
établissements comme les nôtres qui
storiquement il faut bien le dire était
quand même orienté héroïne cocaïne etc
un peu alcool vont devoir développer ses
activités auprès du tabac de l'alcool le
cannabis c'était déjà c'était déjà le
cas une autre évolution
sensible qui est évidente c'est que si
les jeunes vont moins bien et s'il
consomme peut-être moins de cannabis et
tabac si ce qui est bien en revanche qui
se développe c'est les problématiques de
comportement alimentaire avec des
boulimies manifestement à dimensions
addictive ça a été évoqué là sur les les
prises de poids etc et puis également
les écrans les écrans là c'est une
explosion totale là aussi amplifiée par
le confinement très très clairement mais
qui ne diminue pas depuis qui qui se
poursuit or les écrans c'est moins
dangereux pour la santé physique en
revanche c'est pas bon pour la santé
psychique pas du tout c'est un facteur
d'isolement de dépression de conduite
suicidaire etc et on voit en plus qu'il
y a des des au sein de ces addictions là
bon les jeux vidéo ce qui se développe
le plus ce sont de vrais addictions avec
les jeux d'argent de hasard avec la
porno sur internet etc et des dimensions
qui
accident de côté une adaptation parce
que clairement c'était pas notre
savoir-faire de base alors peut-être que
le covid qui nous a permis de développer
des outils de vie santé nous permettra
aussi d'inventer des modalités
d'intervention qui seront peut-être plus
proches de ces usagers bien réels mais
qui sont éloignés de nous qui sont dans
un espace virtuel l'autre dimension qui
est également lié à Internet évidemment
c'est le développement contrepartie des
usages de produits de synthèse en
initialement dans des niches comme les
cam sexuels mais qui se développent
maintenant tout à fait en dehors de ces
niches là dans le milieu festif on pense
au catinon 3 MMC ou également au
cannabis de synthèse mais on pense aussi
à tout ce qui est commandé sur Internet
comme produit industriels il était
évoqué tout à l'heure enfin le GBL en
l'occurrence mais pourquoi pas aussi le
protoxyde d'azote qu'on peut commander
assez facilement etc donc là aussi ça
nécessite des adaptations de notre part
et puis le dernier point que j'évoquerai
c'est en matière de réduction des
risques et d'accès aux soins ça a été
très bien évoqué par Madame saintoyant
je crois qu'il faut voir que la
difficulté aussi que nous avions
peut-être c'est que nous étions dans la
représentation des gens des structures
qui aidaient les gens vraiment à arrêter
totalement définitivement etc ça c'est
le gold standard c'est parfait c'est ce
qu'il faut arriver à faire pour la
plupart des addictions en revanche
beaucoup de d'usagers se reconnaissaient
pas dans ce produit ça n'avait pas envie
il voulait redevenir comme avant et
consommateurs maîtrisés et finalement on
se rendait compte que du coup ces
personnes-là restaient sur la touche
alors même que leur consommation
excessive souvent pour être dommageable
pour leur santé si bien qu'on a
développé des actions qui partent au
plus près des demandes des gens donc
souvent plutôt des actions de
sécurisation des consommations de
diminution des niveaux et y compris par
rapport à l'alcool et y compris dans les
centres sociaux qui étaient évoqués tout
à l'heure avec du coup la possibilité
d'élargir vraiment la palette des
personnes accueillies non seulement des
personnes dépendantes mais également des
personnes qui comme beaucoup d'autres
peuvent des consommations excessives
sans que ça soit nécessairement
dépendante donc ça c'est des des
dimensions qui peuvent être
intéressantes qui sont également
intéressantes en termes de messages
positifs sans doute par rapport aux
jeunes qu'on peut rencontrer à propos
des écrans eux clairement ils veulent
pas arrêter
la dimension qu'on va leur proposer
c'est une dimension de réduction des
risques c'est-à-dire d'arriver peut-être
à continuer à avoir des pratiques qui
peuvent être agréables ou utiles mais
sans perdre le contrôle sans que ça les
isole sans que ça les déprime etc et
c'est ce type de message qui peut être
entendu des messages positifs comme ceux
qu'on développe actuellement on est en
janvier à propos de l'alcool avec le
drive genoahari c'est-à-dire on dit pas
aux gens arrêtez c'est définitivement
c'est une horreur c'est le diable mais
faites l'expérience vous-mêmes d'une
suspension de modération de vos
consommations pendant le mois de janvier
pour voir où vous en êtes par rapport à
l'alcool ce qui vous permettra ensuite
d'avoir une relation plus régulière
voilà je vous remercie merci
vraiment beaucoup de questions on va
faire de salves de questions Chantal de
Seine Michel meunier lance quand même
bouger mes colos Daniel Chassin Chantal
de Seine merci madame la Présidente
merci Madame et messieurs pour votre
présentation je vais parvenir sur tous
les points parce que j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
questions je voudrais vous en posséder
une essentiellement c'est sur les salles
de consommation à moindre risque en
particulier celle de Paris qui nous
alerte depuis plusieurs mois et qui nous
fait part de ces difficultés à prendre
en charge
les personnes sous emprises de drogue et
qui ont besoin d'un suivi en particulier
depuis l'évacuation du square
Perceval je crois force Val pardon
j'avais pas tout à fait les mêmes
références en octobre dernier
difficulté à apprendre en charge ces
personnes parce qu'il manque de
personnel mais parce que aussi la
phylactive a augmenté alors nous avions
fondé beaucoup d'espoir sur cette
expérimentation lancée maintenant depuis
six ans
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
j'espère est après l'expérimentation sur
Paris et Strasbourg une extension
de ces salles de consommation à moins
touristes qu'on a entendu parler de
certains projets sur Marseille sur
Bordeaux mais qui ont avorté ou en tout
cas qui n'ont jamais vu le jour et donc
je voulais savoir quel était la
politique en la matière et si on
envisageait de développer ses salles et
puis une autre petite question et après
je laisserai ma parole à mes collègues
c'est quelle est la situation des
usagers de crack dans le nord-est
parisien en particulier depuis
l'évacuation du square forceval parce
qu'il y avait un dispositif le
dispositif assure qui permettait de les
accompagner en particulier pour ces
usagers en errance en leur proposant des
hébergements dans des chambres d'hôtel
or ils s'avère qu'on n'a pas une offre
suffisante en hébergement et donc quel
dispositif et comment accompagner ce
public particulièrement fragile alors
après je pourrais éventuellement vous
parler de l'addiction au jeu l'addiction
alimentaire qui me préoccupe tout
particulièrement des peufs etc etc mais
voilà je veux pas griller la politesse à
mes collègues et je pense que des
questions complémentaires vous seront
posées je vous remercie merci Michel
merci madame la Présidente merci pour la
présentation très complète et globale de
vos actions moi je vais aller très vite
avec un sujet dont on parlait juste
avant votre mission c'est les JO
l'organisation des JO 2024 et je voulais
savoir en quelle manière de quelle
manière l'ami delka a été associée parce
qu'il y a des questions qui peuvent se
poser sur l'éventuelles dérogation à la
loi Eva donc on parle bien sûr on pense
bien sûr à la consommation d'alcool dans
et hors de l'enceinte mais aussi tout ce
qui est prévention primaire affichage et
on sait que là les sponsors alcooliers
et autres marques liées à du plaisir et
du dépassement sont souvent très pervers
et très pernicieux pour des personnes
concernées par ces produits et ses
comportements addictifs donc voilà je
voulais savoir comment vous avez été
associés à la préparation des JO j'ai
une autre question c'est vous madame qui
l'avez abordé donc les aidants
et particulièrement les aidants des
malades alcooliques sont souvent des
personnes qui souffrent peut-être plus
que d'autres parce qu'il y a un déni
dans l'alcoolisme qui est évident et ces
questions liées à aux violences et
autres sujets que vous avez abordés je
voulais voilà connaître votre approche
d'accompagnement de ces malades est-ce
qu'il y a des actions spécifiques le
protoxyde d'azote vous l'avez aussi
mentionné je voudrais savoir quelles
sont les contrôles réels qui sont faits
sur la commercialisation et la vente de
ces cartouches en grand nombre sur les
sites internet il y a des des
sites qui sont des qui sont dédiés et
qui n'ont de vocation que la vente de
ces produits et je voulais là aussi que
vous nous disiez comment vous contrôlez
et avec combien d'équivalent temps plein
vous effectuez cette mission et puis
j'avais une toute dernière question mais
je suis désolé parce que je vous ai tout
très en différé plus particulièrement
pour la précédente madame de roche je
voulais lui demander si les carrément
été en vente libre et si la consommation
régulière pouvait être considérée comme
une addiction
c'est un peu addictif je reconnecte les
chocolats sont un peu addictifs ils sont
en vente libre ils sont en vente libre
dans deux magasins il y a même des
distributeurs automatiques de Caraman
dans la ville d'Angers pour ceux qui ont
besoin de carrément la nuit ou le
dimanche voilà
moi je trouve que Michel a été très
pertinente et c'est toujours un moment
de douceur on pensait à toi à chaque
fois donc merci ah oui c'est vrai donc
moi je vous remercie Madame et messieurs
pour pour vos présentations j'aurai un
certain nombre de questions à vous poser
concernant des phénomènes qui sont très
très à la mode je pense pas à vous avoir
entendu évoquer le tabac à
en sachet à sucer le sinus qui est très
très en vogue parmi parmi les jeunes
notamment sur Tik Tok et sur un certain
nombre aussi de sportifs et j'aimerais
avoir un peu votre votre évaluation du
phénomène et comment on peut travailler
d'un point de vue préventif ma seconde
question concerne les les cigarettes
électroniques les puffs on n'a pas de
recul insuffisant par rapport à à la
nocivité à l'addiction etc j'aimerais
savoir s'il y a eu des de nouvelles
recherches qui ont été effectuées qui
nous permettent de mieux de mieux
appréhender donc ce que ça le côté
positif et le côté négatif de ces puces
et nous avions voté nous au niveau au
niveau du Sénat sur près d'ailleurs
c'est une proposition de Catherine
procacia de taxer les les pubs ça a été
ça a été voté au niveau du Sénat et
d'ailleurs et je crois que ça a été
enfin ça a pas été maintenu du tout ça a
été rejeté par le gouvernement donc
voilà c'est quand même une vraie une
vraie problématique
mon autre mon autre question c'est que
vous l'avez évoqué effectivement il y a
le tabac l'alcool qui sont en vente
libre mais qui ont des effets absolument
terribles sur la santé sur la santé
publique et à côté de ça il y a
effectivement le cannabis qui
n'est pas en vente libre mais moi
j'aimerais quand même vous entendre sur
le fait que
le le cannabis
je crois qu'on le vit tout et tous que
ce soit en zone urbanisée ou en zone
rurale ça entraîne des trafics
absolument terribles et ces sources de
violence et toutes les politiques qui
ont été menées de sécurité
d'interdiction etc ont été voués à
l'échec je pense notamment à toutes les
politiques qui ont été menées aux
États-Unis mais pas que quand j'avais
travaillé sur la question moi j'avais
j'avais été à l'initiative d'une charte
en 2012 qui avait réuni les principales
associations et les fédérations de lutte
contre les addictions et tout le monde
était arrivé à la à la constatation
qu'il fallait dépénaliser l'usage du
cannabis et je pense qu'après il y a des
évolutions sur la légalisation du
cannabis qui entraînerait justement le
fait de stopper ces trafics et puis de
pouvoir aussi contrôler les choses parce
que aujourd'hui on sait que le cannabis
aujourd'hui n'est plus dosé de la même
façon qu'il pouvait l'être il y a
quelques années donc il y a aucun
contrôle donc moi je ne suis je ne suis
pas convaincu sur le fait que le fait de
de comment dirais-je de
d'accès plus sur le sécurité etc je suis
loin d'être convaincu que c'est le côté
positif donc j'aime j'aimerais avoir
votre votre analyse sur sur cette
question là il m'a toute dernière
question c'est que quand même on
constate que les moyens dont vous
disposez je pense la middelka le web
d'été etc sont des moyens qui sont en
forte diminution au cours des années
Chantal
l'ADIL a évoqué donc c'est quand même un
phénomène énorme et moi je sais que par
exemple pour pour notamment
poursuivre les les trafiquants les gros
trafiquants etc il y a quand même des
moyens qui sont très très très faibles
au niveau de de la police et à tous les
niveaux donc j'aimerais aussi avoir
votre appréciation sur vos propres
moyens pour arriver à répondre à toutes
les questions à toutes les
problématiques qui vous sont demandées
merci gîte alors merci pour votre
présentation l'ami de cas a édité en
2022 un guide le maire face aux
conduites addictives alors j'ai bien
entendu qu'une gavé une cinquantaine de
partenariats et des projets divers je
voudrais savoir quel retour avez-vous de
cette publication j'ai une deuxième
question quel est le bilan après deux
années de mise en place d'amende
forfaitaire délictuel face à l'usage de
stupéfiants et j'ai une troisième
question le Mondial de football vient de
se terminer je voudrais savoir si les
chiffres en c'est vraiment exploser
ça me semble bien
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames messieurs pour votre
présentation donc nous a rappelé
effectivement que le cannabis quand même
usages quotidiens étant augmentation
bien sûr la cocaïne et votre action de
prévention alors il y a quand même dans
ce que nous avait dit il y a des choses
un peu réconfortantes c'est à dire que
l'alcool se diminue chez les jeunes même
si l'augmente dans certaines festivités
moments de façon massive diminution du
cannabis qui est divisé par deux mais
les troubles dépressifs chez jeunes et
développement des des écrans donc mes
questions c'est on a le développement du
protoxyde d'azote enfin qui est arrivé
en milieu rural et quel est son
développement et est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de recrutement
par Internet
est-ce que quels sont les produits qu'il
y a dans la cigarette électronique
est-ce que c'est nocif
et enfin
je pense que en ce qui concerne le
cannabis on se rend compte que
c'est vraiment une plaie effectivement
pour notre pays avec effectivement des
troubles de mémoire et en même temps
psychotique et je pense pas que le fait
de l'égalisation puisque dans d'autres
pays on voit que où c'est légalisé et
bien il y a encore autant au plus de
problèmes
alors je vous laisse répondre puisque
madame citoyenne doit partir assez vite
et ensuite nous aurons nous aurons
[Musique]
d'autres questions
merci madame la Présidente et merci
beaucoup pour toutes vos questions et
observations la plupart d'entre elles
mériteraient un débat en soi donc je
regrette déjà d'avance de répondre sans
doute trop vite et peut-être et sans
doute pas de manière exhaustive donc
j'ai essayé de balayer quelques
principaux sujets et je m'excuse
d'avance de devoir vous quitter ensuite
alors peut-être premièrement sur les
salles de consommation à moins de
risques la situation du crack dans le
nord-est parisien les nouvelles HSA oui
donc il y a eu évacuation du square du
fort cheval au début de l'automne par
les actions conjointes des services de
l'État avec aussi bien sûr l'aide des
des acteurs du monde sanitaire
médico-social et sociales qui qui aident
à la prise en charge des usagers de
crack comme vous le savez c'est une
problématique très complexe peut-être
juste en deux mots pour l'instant il n'y
a pas eu de reconstitution de d'un camp
d'un campement et c'est en particulier
lié à la mobilisation très forte des
forces de l'ordre à Paris
mais cela ne fonctionne que si en
parallèle on offre une prise en charge
adaptée à ces usagers de crack qu'il a
aussi est nécessite une mobilisation
conjointe de tous les services donc
c'est vraiment des efforts à la fois des
acteurs de l'État mais aussi des acteurs
sanitaires et associatifs qui
interviennent au fil de ces usagers donc
le dispositif a sort que vous évoquiez
madame la sénatrice il est poursuivi sa
montée en charge on est après de 600
places offertes il a beaucoup augmenté
tout au long de la crise sanitaire donc
voilà se pose toujours la question
est-ce que c'est suffisant ou pas
suffisant mais c'est un effort
considérable offert ainsi par les
pouvoirs publics et ses partenaires et
qui est un dispositif qui fonctionne
bien puisqu'on a une évaluation en fait
par les les Hospices Civils de Lyon qui
montrent que la prise en charge via ce
dispositif au sort a permis à 87% des
personnes accompagnées de réduire voire
d'arrêter sa consommation donc il n'y a
pas de solution mes miracle en matière
de prise en charge des urée mais des
vraiment des efforts que je souhaite
souligner de tous les acteurs autour de
cette dimension alors oui il y a eu des
impacts aussi sur la salle de
consommation moindre risque à Paris
cette salle on le sait même si elle est
ce dispositif est efficace c'est un
dispositif qu'il s'agit toujours de
conforter de poursuivre dans la durée
parce que la philative est importante
elle reste importante il y a eu des
enfin il y a des difficultés de
recrutement mais malheureusement comme
plus largement aussi dans les les
secteurs sanitaires et médico-social et
sociales donc nous veillons au maximum à
conforter ce dispositif à lui permettre
de bien fonctionner les nouvelles HSA la
politique du gouvernement c'est de
l'accompagner on a des crédits mis en
réserve à cet effet ceux qui l'enjeu
c'est de trouver des alliances
territoriales pour pouvoir le pour
autoriser
ces ouvertures dans les villes on a des
projets effectivement à Bordeaux
Marseille Lille Lyon ces projets ne sont
pas enterrés ils sont en discussion et
mais nécessite vraiment le à la fois la
Louise à son conjointe ça des services
de l'État mais aussi de la collectivité
locale d'implantations et des acteurs
locaux sur le sport les JO la coupe du
monde de foot c'est un effet un enjeu
important sous plusieurs dimensions
parce que il y a une association
malheureuse à notre sens parfois entre
sport et alcool les consommations à
risque d'alcool
aux abords des stades en accompagnement
des événements sportifs donc nous
travaillons avec la Délégation
interministérielle de gestion des grands
événements sportifs la digeste pour
préparer au mieux les prochaines
échéances il y a certes les JO il y a
aussi la Coupe du monde de rugby qui se
prépare avec une dizaine de villes qui
accueillent ces événements donc nous
travaillons pour effectivement faire de
la prévention et réduire les
consommations à risque aussi en régulant
les débits de boissons qui seront
concernés
aussi de lutter contre l'association là
aussi qui n'est pas que positive entre
sport et jeux d'argent et de hasard on a
un sponsoring du monde sportif important
par les opérateurs de jeux d'argent et
de hasard c'est de marier l'image des
transports avec les paris sportifs or
les paris sportifs ils sont malheureuses
et conduisent certes ça peut être une
pratique récréative mais ça devient un
usage problématique pour un certain
nombre de jeunes je parle les jeunes
parce que ce sont vraiment les publics
vulnérables en priorité sur ces
usages paris sportifs un usage
problématique de paris sportifs ça peut
conduire à des problèmes financiers
importants outre la perte de contrôle
etc et qui dit problème financier peut
ensuite conduire aussi à des
comportements voire de délinquance pour
rembourser les dettes donc on a un
engrenage là qui est très problématique
et on est très préoccupé par le
développement à la fois du jeu d'argent
et de hasard en 15 secteur en pleine
croissance mais surtout par le
développement concomitant du jeu
problématique donc effectivement ce sont
des
des liens qu'il s'agit de casser ou au
moins de limiter les nouveaux produits
associés au tabac lesnus enfin le SNU
c'est pas vraiment nouveau mais on a
effectivement un peu d'émergé ensemble
c'est interdit en France donc c'est un
point de vigilance les peurs
effectivement là aussi on se je parlais
tout à l'heure de matraquage des jeunes
publicitaires des jeunes typiquement
c'est un point d'entrée pour l'industrie
du tabac pour toucher aussi les les
jeunes certaines peuvent ou la plupart
contiennent de la nicotine c'est ça le
produit addictif donc on sait que ça
peut être un point d'entrée dans le
tabagisme en tout cas l'addiction à la
nicotine et donc il s'agit de travailler
pour
travailler y compris bien sûr avec vous
parlementaire pour trouver les meilleurs
moyens d'encadrer ces usages
je n'ai pas le temps de plus sans doute
de faire un débat entier sur la
légalisation du cannabis tu as juste
pour appeler la position des
gouvernements qui n'est pas favorable à
ce changement de statut légal pour des
raisons principalement comme conserve
comme pragmatique
[Musique]
le guide du maire donc effectivement
nous sommes heureux d'avoir pu le
diffuser je peux pas vous parler des
valsons d'impact on sent juste que les
exemplaires sont bien partis donc on
espère que c'est effectivement un outil
qui sert à la fois au maire aux élus
mais aussi aux acteurs locaux on sait
que les préfectures s'en servent
beaucoup sinon on leur dialogue avec les
préfectures
et le protoxyde d'azote reste
effectivement un sujet on a quand même
une loi qui a été adoptée en 2021 pour
interdire la vente aux mineurs interdire
la vente dans un certain nombre de
débits se poseraient clairement le la
question des contrôles ne peut qu'en
convenir et comme je le disais ça me
concerne malheureusement pas que le
prototype d'azote mais aussi plus
largement interdiction de vente d'alcool
de tabac de jeux d'argent hasard au
mineur et le protoxyde d'azote et c'est
vraiment un défi pour nous qu'on
aimerait pouvoir relever
merci
vous souhaitez compléter par rapport aux
questions déjà posés le coeur de l'île
peut-être juste quelques mots en
complément pour les salles de
consommation
dorénavant dénommée elle te soins
addiction
on voit bien que la situation est ça
c'est en soi une leçon est très
différente à Paris à Strasbourg
à Paris un problème de massification de
flux massif de d'une population très
très paupérisée très marginale très
visible avec des problèmes de
tranquillité publique que nous nous
retrouvons pas à Strasbourg avec une
population comparable mais en moindre en
moindre effectif une des leçons que l'on
peut tirer je crois en termes
d'adaptation en tout cas c'est une
proposition qu'on avait faite en son
temps au ministre Véran et plus
récemment c'était de plutôt que de
développer dans les villes des gros
dispositifs comme celui de de Paris
essayez de voir des dispositifs
peut-être de plus faibles plus plus
faible ampleur et pourquoi pas des
dispositifs mobiles c'est ceux qui ont
été expérimentés initialement à
Barcelone à Copenhague à Montréal etc
qui répondent à des besoins parce qu'ils
peuvent aller au devant d'usagers qui
sont éloignés mais en allant chez eux
dans les choix de les endroits
différents sans les regrouper dans un
endroit particulier et d'autre part des
dispositifs qui peuvent évacuer si
d'aventures il y a des problèmes de
proximité donc ça va être intégré dans
la loi mais à ma connaissance il manque
des décrets d'application pour que ce
type de dispositif puisse être proposé
alors effectivement il y a différentes
villes de de France là qui ont ce type
de projet avec les difficultés qu'on
connaît en tout cas à Bordeaux pour le
moment le travail continue à Lyon aussi
à Marseille aussi mais il y a toutes les
difficultés qui sont pour partie liées
au retentissement négatif de l'image de
ce qui s'est produit à Paris malgré
l'engagement et le courage de de nos
amis à confronter à une situation et nos
collègues à une situation extrêmement
difficile l'enseignement c'est que les
problèmes d'addiction le disait tout à
l'heure c'est des problèmes mixte c'est
à dire qu'ils vont nécessairement de
pairs avec des problèmes psychologiques
en l'occurrence psychiatrique et des
problèmes sociaux et si on sait on fait
juste une salle de manière isolée
évidemment on va avoir un problème c'est
à dire on va avoir un effet de
sédimentation il faut évidemment
intégrer ces dispositifs c'est le projet
d'ailleurs de l'appellation alte soins
addiction dans une dynamique d'accès aux
soins ouverte sur du soin résidentiel
sur des prises en charge globales
autrement évidemment on risque d'entrer
dans un circuit fermé sur les
e-cigarettes on nous demandait des
données des données récentes il y a des
données récentes il y a eu le rapport du
Haut conseil de santé publique au début
de l'année dernière il vient d'y avoir
un rapport d'une revue Cochrane alors
c'est des méta-analyse médicale mais qui
tentent à ouvrir la porte du côté d'une
relative efficacité des cigarettes dans
l'aide au sevrage ta magique pour des
gens qui veulent arrêter et de fait pour
beaucoup d'usagers là aussi dans une
logique de réduction des risques qu'on
se rend compte que pour des gens qui
sont pas prêts à arrêter tout de suite
brutalement c'est une phase qui peut les
aider à
douceur si j'ose dire à se dégager du
tabac fumé souvent aussi en articulant
avec des patchs nicotiniques mais de
telle façon que progressivement les
personnes pour arriver puissent arriver
à un sevrage donc à mon avis c'est une
piste vraiment à suivre en revanche côté
peuple on est comme tout le monde on est
un peu terrifié par ces nouveaux
dispositifs inventés par le marketing il
y avait des couleurs flashy des goûts
fraises tagada pamplemousse enfin des
choses incroyables qui sont éminemment
ciblées sur les sur les mineurs qui sont
un produit d'entrée et toute mesure qui
pourraient être prises pour restreindre
l'accès à ce type de de produits sera
bienvenu le schness c'est moins moins
présent chez nous il est très porté par
des publicités effectivement par des
sportifs et ça c'est avoir avec les
paris sportifs on fait là il y a une
espèce d'imagerie là qui est qui est
compliqué le protoxyde d'azote on en a
on en a parlé il y a eu de la loi qui
qui est passée là qui est d'une grande
aide il faut vérifier sur le terrain que
ça se passe bien la difficulté c'est que
l'on peut toujours commander sur
Internet dans la mesure des produits
ouverts des bonbonnes tout à fait
considérables et qui ensuite peuvent
être entraînés des intoxications aigus
parce que ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'il
y a des complications sanitaires très
très doivables neurologique et
maintenant hématologie qu'en fait c'est
vraiment quelque chose à surveiller de
de très près voilà est-ce que le crack
est diffusé on avait l'impression que
c'était un phénomène très urbain la
cocaïne on sait maintenant qu'il y en a
partout
même en milieu rural très et même en
milieu très rural est-ce que le crack
est diffusé aussi un peu un peu
globalement sur le territoire français
alors la cocaïne fumée de plus en plus
diffusée largement en emploie ce terme
parce que c'est un peu de la le crack en
tant que tel c'est de la cocaïne basée
donc il peut être fumé parce
qu'autrement la cocaïne normale se dire
se dégrade à la chaleur donc on peut la
on peut la sniffer on peut l'injecter
mais si on la brûle elle va pas marcher
si on a on cherche la fumée donc pour
arriver à faire une une cocaïne qui
puisse être fumée il faut la baser donc
avec une base qui peut être bon enfin
peu importe et soit à ce moment-là on la
base soi-même et c'est ce qui se fait à
la campagne c'est ce qui se fait à
Bordeaux c'est à dire les gens achètent
de la cocaïne et la transforme en craque
mais eux-mêmes en fait avec un technique
de basage avec du bicarbonate ou des
choses comme ça en revanche le crack
vendu d'emblée en tant que craque donc
sous forme de de cristaux ça ça reste
pour le montrer et centré sur les
grandes villes et notamment à Paris il y
avait des populations très original
alors que la cocaïne fumée basée donc
aussi touche les populations marginales
en province dans les Caraïbes mais pas
uniquement c'est-à-dire là on se rend
compte que ça diffuse sur des
populations plus larges y compris les
usagers traditionnels de cocaïques j'ai
juste peut-être revenu fier de
thématique qui ont été abordés
concernant le protoxyde d'azote qu'un
sujet sur lequel l'autre commission et
commission nous avait interrogé au
moment donc la promotion de loi de 2019
juste pour vous indiquer que cette
automne l'Agence européenne des drogues
MCD a publié un rapport sur
l'étendue du phénomène au niveau
européen je pense que c'est un c'est
aussi une ressource intéressante en
termes de mesure de mise en place pour
contrôler la diffusion de ce produit
dans un centre de pays de l'Union
européenne voilà il y a toute une
analyse comparative des législations
prises par les différents pays et on
voit que dans les pays comme les
Pays-Bas ou le Danemark qui sont comme
comme chez nous relativement touché par
ce par ce phénomène chez les jeunes les
dispositifs législatifs qui ont été pris
ou réglementaires ont aussi évolué dans
le temps puisque comme ça a été évoqué
les acteurs de l'offre changent leur
méthode leur méthode de diffusion donc
c'est c'est une ressources tout à fait
intéressante avec des cas d'analyse
thématique par pour six pays dont la
France un premier point il y a eu aussi
un centre de questions sur le sur le
grec et sur la diffusion de la cocaïne
on va nous publier au mois de mars 2023
une synthèse des dernières années est
disponible concernant le l'actualité de
des usages de cocaïne dans ce pays comme
le rappelait Jean-Michel de Lille les
dernières données qu'on a sur les
[Musique]
patients qui sont pris en charge dans
les sapin on voit on a vu effectivement
ces cinq dernières années une très forte
augmentation du nombre de demandes de
traitement pour la cocaïne fumée donc
c'est-à-dire les usagers que une
basilique qui sont donc pour ce qui se
s'improvisait auprès d'un marché
structuré qu'on appelle le crack mais
qui se diffuse comme ça a été évoqué par
Jean-Michel lelil par
de par le basage soit par l'usage et
lui-même soit par des proches mais qui
n'est pas lieu et qui ne donne pas lieu
d'un marché structuré on a assez peu
enfin on a très peu d'exemples de marché
structurés du crack de crack de produits
de crack en dehors de Paris on a il y a
quelques quelques points de vigilance
sur en région on vient de réaliser à la
demande de l'agence régionale de santé
des Pays de la Loire une enquête sur les
sur les effectivement les
usages auprès des publics les plus
précarisés dans les en dehors de de la
métropole nantaise donc
en Mayenne en dans la Sarthe et dans le
Maine-et-Loire donc voilà on rendra
public ces résultats avec l'agence
régionale de santé fin février donc
c'est voilà ces éléments qui seront je
pense au regard de donc ça devrait
pour certains États américains près de
10 ans de de recul sur les effets
effectivement à la fois sur les sur une
plus grande diffusion des consommateurs
afin du produit chez les adultes mais
par ailleurs un vrai contrôle et une
baisse des yeux chez les chez les
mineurs et puis je vais pas le détailler
ici mais un certain nombre de points qui
est de vigilance concernant les
conséquences sanitaires de ces usages en
population adulte voilà c'est ce que je
voulais réévoquer sur sur différents
sujets qui nous concerne directement
juste puisque je sais que la question
des peufs du SNES a été évoquée à
plusieurs reprises ça va être lorsqu'on
fait des enquêtes en population
adolescente ou des enquêtes en général
on a d'abord pour que nos résultats que
l'on obtient nous permettent de les
analyser c'est qu'on doit pouvoir les
comparer dans le temps donc quand on a
des phénomènes marketing qui
apparaissent de manière très très rapide
généralement on est en décalage toujours
dans les dans les enquêtes en 2017 dans
l'enquête escapade on avait manqué
des questions sur le protoxyde d'azote
qui est apparu donc sur le donc il faut
toujours être vigilant sur le fait que
qu'un phénomène s'il est visible
médiatiquement parlant dans la rue n'est
pas forcément traduit pas forcément par
une diffusion massive dans l'ensemble
enfin de manière générale sur toute une
génération de public donc ça c'est ça
c'est un point de vigilance on a pu
poser on l'avait présenté l'année
dernière on sait qu'on a 5,5 % des un
peu moins de 6% donc des jeunes de 3e
qui ont déjà expérimenté le protoxyde
d'azote dans une enquête qu'on mène en
milieu scolaire on va on a René cette
enquête en milieu scolaire en 2000 au
1er semestre 2022 et on aura à la
rentrée donc de septembre 2022 des
nouvelles de données sur la diffusion
effectivement du protoxyde d'azote qui
pourrait être comparé aux données de
2021 donc ça c'est un premier point on
est on sait qu'on est quand même sur un
produit qui est relativement fortement
diffusé auprès des jeunes mais quand je
dis relativement est fortement on est
dans un tour de 10% on n'est pas on
n'est pas la moitié on n'est pas sur des
niveaux la diffusion qu'on a pu
connaître au début des années 2000 comme
je le disais tout à l'heure sur le tabac
ou qu'on le connaît encore aujourd'hui
comme la rappeler citoyens sur l'alcool
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas être
vigilant faut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
contrôler mais il faut effectivement
être attentif lorsqu'il y a des nouveaux
produits voir si c'est effectivement un
phénomène qui qui apparaît qui va
disparaître on avait eu le cas pour les
cigarettes électroniques
marketing type Jules il y a il y a 55 il
faut savoir que les jeunes sont aussi
très réactifs c'est une entreprise qui a
été rachetée par l'industrie du tabac et
qui a en fait qui a quasiment disparu en
fait dans dans les pratiques de
consommation donc la vigilance et ça a
été rappelé à plusieurs reprises sur le
et nous on pose cette question on essaie
de la comprendre dans les enquêtes en
population générale c'est sur ces
cigarettes type puff en fait la question
c'est que les jeunes qui expérimentent
cette théière ne savent pas exactement
ce qu'il fume ce qui ce qu'ils Inal pour
être plus précis s'il y a de la nicotine
il y a pas de la nicotine et l'enjeu
principal c'est effectivement
enfin de prévenir les élections en
nicotine qui peut après entraîner euh
des consommations de cigarettes qui sont
plus facilement accessibles
un docteur
une question très précise sur l'enquête
escapade excusez-moi de ne pas y avoir
répondu donc sinon une enquête qui est
faite auprès de 24000 jeunes qui sont
tirés aléatoirement donc sur enfin non
ils sont pas qui sont qui passent sur
une semaine donnée la journée d'appel
donc la journée défense citoyenneté donc
ils sont convoqués par le ministère des
armées donc c'est c'est aléatoire donc
il y a sans doute des jeunes parmi ces
ces 24000 qui avaient un trouble de la
tension mais nous on ne le sait pas et
les questions qui sont posées en termes
de santé permettront pas de déterminer
mais je suis certain que Jean-Michel
devenu avec sa pratique de terrain
pourra vous donner des éléments par
rapport à ça
oui alors très très rapidement un
premier point sur la prévention suite à
ce qui était dit
à l'issue de festival à La Rochelle je
crois quand des parmi les acteurs
majeurs en matière de prévention il y a
les personnes elles-mêmes et notamment
les jeunes et on sait que les messages
portés par des jeunes même sont souvent
plus accessibles et plus compréhensibles
les plus acceptable surtout par par
d'autres jeunes alors là ce qui nous
sert en gros de mon point de vue
notamment par rapport à des produits
comme le cannabis c'est paradoxalement
l'explosion des usages à la fin des
années 90 ce qui fait que beaucoup de
jeunes sont devenus des usagers de
cannabis mais beaucoup ont vu aussi les
dégâts que ça faisait sur d'autres
jeunes si bien qu'ils ont pu juger par
eux-mêmes que le cannabis n'était pas
aussi inoffensif que ce qui était dit
auparavant nous en fait il y avait deux
visions cloisonnées et les jeunes
pensaient que c'était il y avait rien à
craindre c'était une panacée et les
adultes en gros pensaient que c'était
pas bon dangereux donc c'était assimilé
discours moralistes alors que là en fait
la réalité éclate c'est
ce qui va apparaître bientôt et le
protoxyde d'azote c'est à dire que les
jeunes eux-mêmes se rendent compte que
finalement c'est pas anodin et peuvent
développer des messages de prévention
qui sont très utiles quitte à charge à
nous ensuite de les relayer y compris
sur les réseaux sociaux et sur les les
supports médias utilisent les les jeunes
même donc ça à mon avis c'est une grosse
piste vous ne deveniez si nos moyens
étaient suffisants non les moyens de
prévention pour l'aspect consultation
jeune consommateurs c'est-à-dire
repérage précoce prévention primo
secondaire ça c'est intégré à notre
dotation globale donc globalement ça ça
fonctionne en revanche là où il y a des
gros problèmes c'est toutes les actions
de prévention autre sont financés à
l'année et pratiquement donc avec
l'insécurité qu'on connaît tous dans ce
type de problématique alors sur le TDAH
donc le trouble déficit de la tension
avec hyperactivité clairement parmi les
troubles neuro-développementaux c'est
celui qui est le plus prédictif de
risque de passage à l'addiction au
moment de de l'adolescence il y a un
lien structurel très très important qui
nécessite là aussi des cloisonner les
filières santé mentale pédopsie et
de telle façon que on sait bien le
repérage précoce du TDAH et son
accompagnement son traitement précoce
c'est vrai aussi pour le troubipolaire
chez les enfants peut permettre de
réduire à ce moment-là le risque
d'évoluer vers une addiction donc ça
c'est bien
[Musique]